it's finally here push your video
settings to 1080p and just look at that
detail we no longer have to listen to
the despair of PC players who haven't
even played yet so many people telling
me that they can't watch my videos till
the 25th and these are people who had
the fortitude to wait and have the best
first experience they could with a new
souls game so is it worth buying well
let's look into that for you but
hopefully the footage will speak for
itself and as you can see it's pretty
great the souls series is renowned for
its rich gameplay and whatever platform
you buy this on your going to have a
great gameplay experience because of the
satisfying combat and the brilliant
atmosphere which will be similar on
console or PC to buy a souls game for
the graphics is to miss the point
entirely
that said the overall experience is
undoubtedly better on PC to the point
where I can confidently say that you
won't be able to go back to console
after playing it and I know I won't be I
felt way more engaged with the PC
version and this is for three main
reasons one resolution - frame rate and
three and most importantly in my opinion
loading screens these loading screens
last for like three seconds
so the difference with these three
things is a big deal this time around
and if you can buy it on PC then I see
no reason why you shouldn't and if you
can't buy it right now well it's on
Steam man you can always wait for those
killer steam sales most of you should
own a decent PC and from what I hear
most of you will be able to play it on
PC because Dark Souls 2 on PC seems to
run on higher settings on most mid-range
systems so on the left you have Dark
Souls on ps3 being recorded with HDMI at
720p in 30 frames per second on the
right is Dark Souls PC in 1080p
uncompressed and recorded through fraps
at 60 frames per second but before I go
any more in depth let me say this
YouTube compresses video and only runs
at 30 frames per second so if you're
watching on YouTube both left and right
screens will only be showing in 30
frames now in order to get a proper
comparison at 60 frames per second and
full resolution click the first link in
the description to download the original
video that hasn't been through the
YouTube application
process if you're thinking of buying
this game or if you plan on leaving one
of those console walk comments down
below then you should really watch that
first oh and make sure to make fun of
that one guy in the comment section who
didn't listen to me and says I can't
notice a difference in framerate anyway
without further ado let's start by
comparing loading times so this makes a
bigger difference than you'd think in
Dark Souls 2 on console you spend a long
time on loading screens more than we've
ever seen on console before with my ps3
taking about 30 seconds in many cases to
load the warping between zones you spend
a long time in loading screens because
eh you'll die a lot and be because you
spend more time warping between areas
than ever before in a souls game with
the new bonfire system so just look at
the difference here I can get through
two or three loading screens in the time
it takes me to do one on ps3 Dark Souls
2 on PC consistently loads these screens
in about 3 to 4 seconds on my hard disk
drive and I reckon installing the game
on a solid-state drive could lower these
times even further so I'd recommend that
if you have an SSD you should have an
SSD SSDs are awesome so yeah fast
loading screens make the game a much
more engaging experience especially
since you have to walk back to majula
all the time and on ps3 I started to
harbor this ill feeling towards majula
as an area because I knew I would have
to devote 30 seconds of idle time
waiting for that loading screen every
time I wanted to spend my souls and
medulla is meant to be a home of sorts
going there and spending all your souls
is something you're meant to be looking
forward to doing and you shouldn't come
to hate the experience so it was
surprising how much of a difference the
3-second load time makes moving on let's
talk about frame rate of frame rate
there's nothing more attractive in a
game everything looking smoother makes a
world of difference and it really
affects your immersion and the gameplay
so like I mentioned before Dark Souls 2
now runs at 60 frames per second on PC
compared to a more or less stable 30
frames per second on console if you want
to see that difference watch the video
outside of youtube and download a sample
in one of the links in the description
60 frames per second is a hell of a
difference especially in intense combat
where you
need to have that fine motor control
over your character I played all the way
through to the Dragon Eyrie just for
this video just so I could see what it
was like in 60 frames per second looks
amazing doesn't it alright so let's talk
about resolution dark souls 2 on PC will
render any resolution supported by the
system right now you're looking at 1080p
footage which will be the standard for
most of your setups but depending on
your setup I believe you can get up to
4k resolution if you have the capability
I can only imagine how gorgeous that
would look so already dark souls 2 PC is
a far cry better than dark souls on PC
it supports sixty frames second
rendering at 1080p and Beyond and this
just shows that it's not a port of the
game it's been developed from the ground
up to an extent so however this is the
standard we come to expect from PC game
developers so let's see if they exceeded
expectations in other areas according to
an article in PC gamer which I
referenced throughout this video and
I'll talk about later the game data
archives for PC are ten point seven
gigabytes compared to the five point
seven gigabytes of the ps3 version and
it's confirmed that the five gigabyte
difference is due to higher quality
asset data for example this file appears
to store higher resolution assets for
special effects such as torchlight or
particles and it's twice as large as the
file in consoles so there's a visible
difference here as you can see in the
torchlight and the sparks but designer
side textures were already decent on
console and they scale nicely with the
settings on PC in regards to performance
my system is a few years old at this
point it's probably considered a mid
range system with a gtx 660ti and a core
i5 357 TK 8 gigs of ram i run this game
in 1080p with all settings turned to max
and i've never experienced a single drop
below 60fps except when i'm recording at
the same time with fraps so the minimum
requirements and the recommended
requirements are going to be listed in
the description so you should check that
out to see if you can run it according
to other reviewers though I believe even
low to medium systems should be able to
run this with few problems and mid-range
systems and above will run
this game without missing a beat on the
highest settings keyboard and mouse
controls the next thing I want to talk
about I know how terrible they were in
the original Dark Souls port but these
are well implemented this time around
they've even got the mouth showing up in
all in-game menus which is a nice touch
the only problem is that Xbox button
prompts will show up on your screen when
you're playing with a mouse and a
keyboard and this is something that
should have been changed but it can be
something that's patched in as well so
we'll see
regardless mouse and keyboard controls
are wonderful footage on-screen is me
playing with the keyboard and mouse with
almost no practice at all and to my
surprise I wasn't playing like complete
crap the controls are really precise and
completely configurable now I still
recommend playing Dark Souls with the
controller and this goes for more
third-person games but these controls
will be such a welcome change for many
PC players who don't own a gamepad and I
still reckon you could be just as good
with a bit of practice this really
surprised me actually the controls are
intuitive and things like switching
targets with a mouse swipe are
implemented really well let's talk about
future modding I'm certain there's going
to be some ways of modding the game and
will likely cover these on the channel
at some point you guys remember my Dark
Souls modded series you guys might also
remember Durante who created dsfix for
Dark Souls PC I'll talk about him a bit
later in the video
but he's already reviewed the PC version
of Dark Souls 2 and he's planning on
seeing what he can do to improve it in
the future anyway back to modding it's
possible but as usual it's not directly
supported by from software so it's going
to be interesting to see how things
develop it's also worth noting that I
believe Steam has ways of detecting a
program called cheat engine in use which
is what I use for a lot of my videos to
make them better and it's also what a
lot of hackers use so it'll be
interesting to see how easy that is to
use this time around now let's do the
really interesting comparison let's
compare two pre-release ps3 footage now
most people remember the ps3 demo
footage we were shown in promotional
trailers for Dark Souls 2 and it's been
something of a problem for a few people
since it looks amazing compared to the
game we got on ps3 and even on the PC
version so let's take a look on the left
is pre-release ps3
demo footage and on the right is the PC
version as you can see the demo has
really overdone particle effects and the
lighting and textures are also really
impressive considering especially that
it's running on ps3 there are also a few
design changes so whether it looks that
good or not isn't simply because of the
graphics it's also because the lighting
and the contrasts looks way different
now I play the TGS demo build on the
left and I can attest that the footage
looked like this while I was playing on
ps3 which was pretty amazing there are
two reasons it looks better one effects
were incredibly enhanced in the demo
version weapons and torches generated a
quantity and depth to their particle
effects that is just simply not present
in the release versions of the game some
effects like using life gems were
ridiculously over-the-top
however when fighting the Maronite in
the ps3 demo I did notice a few
framerate drops so my theory and it's
backed up by some developer comments is
that they developed for the demos
without worrying too much about frame
rate and then scaled it down for release
versions it's also likely that they over
developed the sections we saw in
promotional footage and then lowered its
resolution and particle effects in
return for a stable framerate the burden
was on from to put out a demo
representative of the final game and
they messed that up it's worth noting
that I fully believed the demo version
of Dark Souls 2 used in Namco's
marketing was all they had access to
when the trailers were made the fault
came when other versions of the game
were released for testing closer to
release but the discrepancy between the
demo and the alpha versions didn't make
it through to consumers this wasn't
enough of a priority for those behind
the marketing because they
understandably want to showcase the best
parts of their game Plus based on what
I've seen they were only given the demo
to draw inspiration from hopefully a
realistic representation is higher on
the agenda next time around and I think
you just shouldn't trust promotional
footage until then the thing that's
really baffling to me and it's not the
stuff I just mentioned I think I can get
over that but the thing that's really
baffling is what I'm going to explain
next contrast in the demo versions
blacks were darker in the released
version the game looks washed out and
there's practically never a reason to
use a torch so as a result of this when
you make the game darker through
brightness settings and switch
RGB full-range in your console settings
from limited to full then the visuals
will improve substantially even then
though you can still see in the dark and
it just doesn't reach that level of
ambience it had in the demo version
torches were the thing I was most
excited about in this game they had this
potential to be a brilliant mechanic
where you could forego your shield for a
time limited light source to see enemies
coming at you in the dark or use the
shield to protect yourself for the
horrors in the dark when I played the
ps3 demo I was legitimately wary of what
would come out of the pitch blackness
dungeon crawling in this way felt
intense and it felt like you were
fighting for every inch of space you can
get in front of you on the other hand
using a torch meant you wouldn't get
this experience but enemies would be
harder to fight because you wouldn't
have a shield and if your light went out
during battle because you switch to a
shield or you ran out of torch would you
would scramble to find your way in the
dark and you would try to find a way out
of the darkness you've been plunged into
or maybe you'd try to defend yourself
from enemies who all of a sudden got
this slight advantage alas all this was
changed in both the PC and console
versions and what we ended up with was a
light source that makes the area around
you prettier that's it and that's just
because you can still see in the dark
incredibly well even when you're in a
completely closed off room or cave that
has no right to be as light as it is so
even if you turn your brightness way
down which you shouldn't have to do pass
the recommended setting the dark areas
are still able to be seen not only does
this decision make no sense I mean why
did they incorporate the lighting system
in the first place if not to have an
awesome mechanic revolve around it but
it's fixable of all the little patches
that would make a world of difference I
reckon this is one of them the gutter is
my favorite area simply because you have
to use a torch to traverse it and so
many other areas in this game would be
made immeasurably more atmospheric and
fun to draw verse if the darkness was
deeper so what do we do about the
dissonance between the demo and release
versions it's up to you to decide how
much it upsets you if I didn't know
about graphical dissonance I would come
to the conclusion that Dark Souls 2
looks and performs wonderfully on PC and
very very acceptable
on last gen consoles but since we know
about the difference in footage we feel
like we've had something taken from us
and we feel as if we're not getting the
product we're shown my opinion on this
is that it's clearly wrong to be shown
something and have it not represent the
final product so all I can say is that I
advise you not to trust promotional
footage or at least just be wary of it
in terms of graphical fidelity until a
company proves that this is higher on
their agenda next time but generally I
don't think it's that big of a deal the
graphics of the SOL series have never
been a selling point and it's silly to
focus on this at the expense of all else
the thing I'd rather people focus their
energy on complaining about is the lack
of dark areas which was a wonderful
mechanic shown and then taken out for no
apparent reason other than to make a
dark area lighter at the expense of a
clearly amazing mechanic for atmosphere
and gameplay which is a real oversight
on frumps part in my opinion but hey
that's just one gripe with a game that I
generally think is pretty amazing and I
think one thing with the SOL series is
we always want the game to be better
there's always a few things we can see
that could be improved and I don't think
there's anything wrong with wanting that
in regards to the settings of the PC
version and what every one of them does
there's an excellent guide written by a
Durante over on PC gamer comm for those
of you who don't know Durante is the guy
who developed this little miracle called
DS fix for Dark Souls 1 PC it turned the
PC port for Dark Souls 1 from a terrible
shameful port into what we deserved he
improved the framerate allowed us to
alter settings improved mouse and
keyboard controls and gave us all the
settings we wanted from a PC game he's
someone from our community who went
above and beyond and he did a great
service for us he did a great service
for from software and also Namco Bandai
making us all forget what a terrible
shame Dark Souls was on PC I mean think
about this from Namco and from his point
of view this guy single-handedly saves
Dark Souls PC from a world of criticism
I think I speak on behalf of everybody
and that's Namco that's from software
and that's all consumers who use dsfix
when I say thank you and hey I've
managed to find his donation page online
where he's probably earned a fraction of
what he deserves
for creating and support
dsfix for years even when darksouls pc
was updated and his mod was made
obsolete he went back numerous times and
fixed it so it would work the link to
this PayPal donation page is on the
second line in the description and if
you have a couple of bucks left over
from buying the pc version i don't i
can't think of anyone better to throw
them to and back to the pc version of
Dark Souls 2 I do think it's worth Abay
especially if you have anything near a
mid-range or if you're enough of a soul
span to warrant getting the definitive
version and most of you on this channel
might just be that it undoubtedly is the
better version while we might never get
the truly next-gen product that was
displayed in TGS demos we received
something that was a damn sight better
than most PC versions and a damn sight
better than what I was worried we would
get this is a company that has really
little experience in the PC space and
hey the game is also available on Steam
so if you don't have enough for a full
price copy right now then just watch
that price drop rapidly in the next few
months and years and pick it up them if
you enjoy my videos feel free to click
here and figure out what kindling the
channel is all about the next video is
going to be a big one most likely so
look forward to that I'll catch you guys
next time later
[Music]
you